thank you so much
and i'll take your jacket when you're
ready
so we're going to do the um other
workers and the governor will get the
last
shot so if you want to say a couple
things to the folks here about why
you're no i appreciate you being here
and having the opportunity to be here
with these folks today and
share a bottle of vaccines with them uh
they've been
that's like you know uh they've been
incredible supporters i mean they've
worked on the front lines through this
entire time
you know dealing with the pandemic and
these are folks that came to work
every single day when if you remember
these shelves were empty and you
couldn't buy toilet paper and you
couldn't buy rice or beans or
uh they worked around the clock face
change your schedules
in order to accommodate all the people
that were coming in here to do their
shopping which says an awful lot they
sent me the hours
they worked overtime and they put
themselves at risk and then they had to
deal with people who didn't want to wear
a mask
or didn't want to follow the rules and
they've been incredible
examples and i'm thrilled about the fact
that you know they're all in the queue
now they can all get the vaccine and
it's an honor to be here at albertsons
and have a chance to share a vile
vaccine with them so
ready to go
okay question
yeah our goal is to get vaccines needles
in as many arms as we possibly can
uh there's an awful lot of people in the
hospitality entertainment business that
it's important we get vaccinated
i've always said that it's uh i want to
make las vegas and nevada the safest
place
and healthiest place where people come
to you're having a convention
don't go to texas or florida come to las
vegas i mean we're vaccinating our
frontline workers
so it makes it safer for them for their
families for all the guests that we're
bringing in all the convention years
and that's why we want to make it as
safe as possible can you speak to
how the supply is starting to outpace
the demand for there's not as many
people throwing up the vaccine sites is
there
initially in nevada yeah no we the
supply is not outpacing the demand we've
got huge amount of demand we're just
increasing
some of the capacities a little bit
we're still trying to get more and more
vaccines into nevada and
we're getting our allocation increase
every week which is certainly helping us
uh but what we're doing by having the
hospitality and
food service workers because we're
expanding them to 50
next week uh i think that's a good thing
that you're they're gonna be able to
come in here get their vaccine to feel
safer
when they're out in the community and
dealing with customers
how the next age about that'll be
allowed to
start getting vaccinated the next age
group that's on the uh
the playbook is going to be 16 through
or 18 through 64
with underlying conditions and that's
what we're trying to get to
we're trying to get the people that are
most susceptible and
vulnerable to the disease and that's
what we're doing so the next group will
be the
18 to 64 with underlying conditions
or is there going to be any increase in
the timeline
for 50 percent businesses
yeah we're moving forward with all of
the restrictions you're going to see a
lot of them ease next week you know that
and we're going to see how quickly we
can get vaccines in arms how many we can
get in arms
and then you're aware that in may we
plan to turn this over to local
jurisdictions
some of them are further ahead on the
vaccines that clock is but hopefully
everybody
in a good position by that point we'll
be able to extend it all
i just want to clarify today when we
announced that we're moving to
hospitality
it also mentioned that we're looking to
do 55 plus with underlying conditions by
end of next week so that was in the same
release with the hospitality workers so
you all should have that there
as far as the governor's office and all
your employees that work for you
after you get yours today how many still
will there be to go
i didn't do the analysis that we did in
my office we did the people that have a
front uh facing with the public
and those that are part of the uh
governance issue the ones that are
working from home
can work from homes and they're younger
they haven't gotten there
but perhaps in the next couple weeks i
hope in the next couple weeks you'll be
able to open up more and more and more
as we get the vaccines we will be able
to open it up and
now with three vaccines available it's
certainly helping giving us more options
to get into the uh
locations and that's what we've been
doing this for so long for
governor the uh guidance on
nursing home investigations um does
nevada plan on following that
too by changing some of the restrictions
yeah we're looking at you know the
restrictions going into nursing homes
it's been a very very difficult
situation people haven't been able to
get in and see their loved ones and
i can tell you that you know my mom
lives with my sister but the biggest
thing she looks forward to
seeing at rankin and that's what folks
really want to do so work with the
nursing home association to try to
loosen those up
to try to get families coming back
together because it's been difficult
it's been a year
i mean we started talking about this a
year ago and i would have never imagined
a year ago
we'd still be here today but we are so
i'm happy the pace we're going but we
got a lot further to go
i do not know any progress on senior
officials about
the allocation algorithm on because
nevada has had a big
yeah i talked with the president's task
force and we deal with that and
they've been using this older data and
unfortunately this is
disadvantage for nevada and some other
states that have an influx of people
especially older people
retirees that have moved here and some
of the ones that have lost population
they've gotten the benefit from this
they said they're aware of the new data
they're going to implement it as quickly
as they can but as for right now
they're sticking with the old the old
set of data and uh
we're encouraging them to look forward
and move that on
what are your priorities as far
yeah and i really appreciate we had our
you know both of our centers and three
of our congress
people voted for that uh congresswoman
titus congressman horsford and
congresswoman late
and senators uh rosen and uh cortes
master certainly
uh we're gonna work with the legislature
in order to allocate that now there's
some
flexible money that's coming from the
federal government they'll come to the
state
there's flexible money coming from the
federal government to the counties in
the cities
and then there's certain pockets of
money that's also available i mean the
school district clark county school
district is getting hundreds of millions
of dollars
that's specified and then there's other
money that's specified it could be for
rental assistance it could be for a
vaccine distribution or whatnot
we don't want to use our flexible money
to fill those needs we want to try to
get as much of that as we can too so
we're working closely
with our delegation in washington and
the legislature come up with a way to
allocate responsibly the funds that
we're gonna get
so governor you're up next it looks like
we'll finish one more and then it'll be
your turn
i let the folks know that uh what was
available today was the jansen the j
vaccine for you so that's what you'll be
getting
yeah and i really appreciate that right
now we are still
really focusing on those 65 and over
it's extremely important that that
vulnerable part of the population
we get in for vaccines so if you're 65
and over and you haven't gotten it
please come on down there's vaccine
vaccination sites all over the place to
get it if you know someone
who's 65 or over and hasn't gotten it
you know we've seen the best in people
during this pandemic people going out of
their way to help their neighbors and
their family and their friends and
whatnot
if you know somebody that's 65 and
doesn't have transportation or can't get
there
you know phone call to them and say hey
look let's make an appointment i'll take
you down there would really go a long
long way
and it's something that we'd really
appreciate uh them helping out in that
way because
there's a lot of folks in that age group
that don't have transportation or can't
get to a bus line immediately
but it's the most important thing we're
still fighting for we want to get 75-80
percent of that population group
and we're still short of that right now
so we're encouraging anybody that's
over 65 to certainly get in get vaccine
and
now that we've opened up for those with
underlying conditions 55 and above
please come in get a vaccine and
whatever the underlying condition is
whether it's
asthma diabetes whatever it might be
just don't think twice but come on down
and we'll do what we can
good so we'll have
gov get a shot and then we'll try to
turn the store back over to albertson
if that's okay thank you albertsons for
helping us out here we appreciate that
thank you thank you
how are you sir
all right
okay ask aloud because you want to hear
these questions
do you have any of the following
symptoms that are unusual for you
paul shortness of breath short sore
throat chills congestion or runny nose
no all right do you have diarrhea or
nausea vomiting
no hey do you have a female yeah in
front of all these people
no people okay you're good the left arm
is okay
i know
now everybody that comes out here isn't
going to get this young lady to do the
vaccination because you have to have a
day off but
yes i do
i'm not afraid of needles i'm not afraid
of you
you're getting ready yes sir
thank you this is my full pharmacy
friend a full pharmacy
pharmacy school of pharmacy kids
you can
thank you
okay it was totally pain free
it was a very simple procedure and i
encourage everyone i beseech everyone
please
please if you're eligible down to the
vaccination site
please get it make an appointment and
show up for your appointment it's going
to make a difference
there's a light at the end of this dark
tunnel that we've been going through
we're a lot closer to the end
of this pandemic than we are at the
beginning and these vaccines are what's
going to make the difference so i
encourage everybody out there if you're
eligible or when you become eligible
to get your vaccine please do it as soon
as you possibly can and
all three of the vaccines are terrific
and i encourage them just to get
whatever one's available
great thank you all for coming any other
questions before we give albertsons our
store man
okay thanks everybody i appreciate it